[Music]
all right how many of you have seen
the steve busami mean meme how do you do
i know where this is going i know where
this is going how do you do fellow kids
yeah have you seen this before wait was
that on 21 jumps where is that from is
that twenty one
i love that i love that meme i use that
meme all the [ __ ] great meme it's
basically like it's not from 21 jump
street that would be good it's from uh
30 rock i believe yeah he's like trying
to blend in with the kids and so i was
like how do you do fellow kids he's
really funny on like these little now a
two million dollar nft is it i don't
know that'd be great yeah probably damn
steve
dude he looks he's like one of the most
creepiest looking dudes ever but i love
whatever he makes for halloween he went
as his own as the meme [ __ ] legend
why does he look younger here than the
other bit like what
because they're not playing up the
creepy i feel like a 30 rock they're
playing i lit him and made him up at the
makeup skinny and creepy what's the like
mustache beard the craziest thing about
this mother doesn't even look like him
he's looked this age for the past 40
years i know it's insane yeah his range
crazy since he was 20 he was was he on
godfather like when did he first come
out i'm not sure he was in [ __ ] uh
desperado the antonio banderas film
really he was in the beginning where he
was in the bar talking about the legend
he was in the con air too he was the
crazy guy with the with the mask now
he's been around for [ __ ] some time
dude that's when i first saw him yeah
and then he was having tea with the
little girl put the money down he's a
crazy guy right he's in the big lebowski
he was donny dude he's so good in big
lebowski he's great have any of you guys
seen boardwalk empire yeah yeah i heard
it was really good it's really
interesting to watch because he's like
ugly he's really ugly and the the entire
show is trying to paint him as like the
guy that everybody wants to focus so
it's got someone it doesn't make sense
yeah there's this weird cognitive
dissonance when you like watch the show
you're just like
you ain't that hot dude i don't know if
they're all trying to [ __ ] you stevie
hey uh what's that movie with uh it was
with will ferrell and um is it matt
damon with a buddy cop oh yeah yeah mark
wahlberg wahlberg there you go yeah that
was the same [ __ ] that they're doing
with wilfred that [ __ ] was so [ __ ] so
funny yeah michael keaton was great in
that too yeah he was the cover of the uh
the tlc lion it was so so good
the rock was it don't go chasing water
and samuel jackson jump off the [ __ ]
building did you hear the new uh the
rock's new rap song no it's bad it's so
bad hey shout out to everybody in the
comments that said that he was a good
rapper [ __ ] you who said that everybody
they're like dude they're people are
doing uh uh they actually think he's a
good rapper i think they're doing
because they want rock to feature them
on their instagram so they're like yo
rock's [ __ ] i was like bro but you
know what's annoying is that it's like
and it's just stuck in my head
you know what it sounds like it sounds
like he's being the guy from moana but
just like sing rapping maui yeah that's
what he sounds like he doesn't sound
like he's rapping like he he enunciates
he not says everything so well like i
don't really like that he sounds
terrible apparently he's not good he's
not good apparently he did it in one
take he probably did because he had no
[ __ ]
they're saying like he only did it in
one tank and david's like yeah yeah
he should have done it in a couple more
takes and perfected it did you know that
i never practiced this oh really
i had no idea i had no professional
training william hung [ __ ] right there
he's probably not professional he
probably also didn't give them a second
take he was like okay now i have to
leave bye i gotta go work out some more
of some [ __ ] i love the rock i love the
rock i [ __ ] love it doesn't mean that
that [ __ ] wasn't trash dude this is the
second time we [ __ ] on him today though
i love the man i just don't want to hear
him rap yeah exactly why does he why
does he need to rap though because he's
the [ __ ] who asked him to run dude he
can't be stopped bro he launches a
tequila company everyone's buying us
together he's like i think everything i
do is [ __ ] amazing
he has an energy drink now too exactly
have you tried it one of the biggest
energy rings out there now is it good
what is it zola
all over every hawaii hawaiian market
store yeah if bart was like three
thousand percent more delusional he
would be the rock that's right yeah but
unfortunately he's gonna get he's gotta
get like three thousand percent you're
not buff enough bro i'm not delusional
let me take my steroids
yeah how much how much roy's do you
think he's taking because he's a [ __ ]
ton dude he's ginormous he's actually
way leaner now than he was in the wwe
dude he's so much leaner do you remember
when he was in that movie just after wwe
the rundown the rundown bro he's skinny
as [ __ ] when he was in the wwe i
wouldn't be surprised he was actually
was natural because he just comes from
great genetics right yeah um but now
he's just like no one gets older and
more lean and ripped and bigger at the
same time just the boulder now the
boulder
the mountain side
dude look at this little [ __ ]
that's true that's pretty normal wait is
that did he always have that tattoo or
is that new or is it or is that like is
that like a thing for the movie did you
always have that tattoo yeah he has the
bull on the other side yeah yeah because
does that mean she's pretty tall she's
probably he's probably staying on
appleby like the tom cruise treatment
one of the things that i disliked when
rock got on the instagram was his fake
laugh
always fake laughs now it's like come on
what if he's just so sexy that is his
real life that's his uh hello cool j
laughing [ __ ] now the [ __ ] do an
impression of his laugh how does it goes
good morning uh i'm here drinking my
tara monica tequila
[ __ ] me
every [ __ ] video it's like come on
rob you don't gotta do we love you man i
gotta follow this guy you don't follow
him what are you kidding me cause dude i
don't need more of that stuff on my feet
i stopped following a lot of celebrities
too how come they're annoying does it
depress you joe does it make you sad no
i want to be with my friends that's real
that's from like a [ __ ] hillbilly bro
because one of the things everyone says
is i don't want to look at social media
because it makes me depressed because
i'm comparing myself to other people's
reaction i don't like it when my feed is
so full with like people that i don't
know
and then hot girls and then by the time
i actually get to one of you guys it's
like man your lives are just not as fun
as the rock so let me take you out you
need to lower your expectations for the
rest of it so you unfollow your friends
and stay followed to the right i should
have right
because he excites me more than my
friends
but like him and kevin hart are the same
person now you think they hang out a lot
and that's what happened i think you
know they do the same thing now they're
the same brand kind of they're the same
brand just two different people i don't
know i did a movie with kev and i don't
remember the rock being around too much
so just all right this is a good just to
drop that out of the future
what movie did you do with it was called
the wedding ringer oh [ __ ] you guys did
that i was in the film as well and you
were in it yeah i mean yeah yeah hung
out and hanging out on set hey i did a
sketch with uh kev hart okay
good old uh we call him kevi oh you're
home can you i just call him okay all
right okay
you know he just had a great old time he
saw his hands in the business what was
he like in person very soft hands very
cool his hands are very soft does that
check out steve not as soft as john
witherspoon's corpse
all right pete r.i.p alright
i tried to name-drop you i'm like well
that was just in my head because earlier
who's the best name drop you have bart
no one i don't think i know that many
cool people no that's something that's
john monday ramsay's not too uh
john benay ramsay careful voice in your
life
careful boy
gotta be careful oh [ __ ]
shout out to the kid kevlar he's
actually really nice
he's just so busy i've never seen a guy
on his phone as much as this dude he's
didn't come in to shoot and just bounce
he came in the chute he finds his car
flew off at his private jet so good like
not even a joke that's exactly where was
it where was it shot at it was in his
studio a lot oh he has his own studio
yeah oh because he has his own studio
lot called the people at that company
were so [ __ ] funny because after we
did that sketch right invite you we
didn't get paid for it i don't think
yeah and then they go okay cool like kev
wants to do two more sketches with you
and i'm like that's cool am i gonna get
paid and i know you just have a chance
to work with him again i'm like okay
what the [ __ ] are you talking about it's
like you're gonna get excited like yeah
i get to work with them again yeah it's
like we already did two sketches like i
got a soft surf business is going down
is he gonna come out and shout me out
[ __ ] have him hold it up for me
please i know i just do this can i
slowly just bring in a softer code a
little higher
say the line save the line i have a
buddy that does stunt work for most of
the rocks movies because he's pretty
tall so you like the rocket throw them
around and he says in between every take
immediately as soon as they all cut
like four lawyers four people come up to
him they all asking for answers jesus
like what what what about this big
energy jig what about this we want this
what about this uh um the tequila is now
open in the south american market we
don't do this it's like there's no time
to hang out or anything like that for
six months it's like that's how kid is
yeah as soon as he's cut boom and then
he doesn't have time to read lines for
his movies so he's literally looking at
the script and he just does it and then
he gets out it's crazy i can't wait to
live live live that sounds amazing how's
that john witherspoon's feud with his
funeral
and uh everybody he wasn't even there
for very long
he was [ __ ] out of there everyone was
asking questions of the corpse
did people stay for this whole cert like
service or did they just come in and
leave no they was they stayed for the
whole thing oh my god his finalist was
very intimidating yeah right exactly
old cab though is the best because i did
like two scenes with the guy right and
then uh we did a music video like i
don't know three months later where we
all got back together either the whole
cast and okay
and uh and he walks in the room and like
he's clearly like you know josh gad's
there and like all these guys and then
he looks at me like he's never seen me
before in his entire [ __ ] life and
then he's like how you been man
that's the best you're not looking you
get people you're like i've never met
you ever hi good to see you again but
then you see it you see it in their eyes
that they know you and you're just like
oh [ __ ] okay turn it on turn it on turn
on
if i wish he meets like a thousand
people in the matter of like two hours
exactly he can't hold it against old
kevi
okay
it would have been better if he
reintroduced himself to you again do you
think that would have been heartbreaking
no because i didn't expect him to know
me at all like i have no ego at all i'm
like what if he did it like ten more
times i will tell you i will tell you
this though something that did make me
feel good was that his whatever
representative said that out of all the
sketches he was he was the i was the
only person that he laughed at it seemed
like on that video you guys had a good
time we were crack i was dying laughing
so i mean we were just showing him naked
pictures of me that was a really good
[ __ ]
got his ass he was like what the [ __ ] is
he have seen those yeah so i was like oh
i actually made this guy [ __ ] laugh i
didn't think it was going to happen it
seemed like you guys knew each other
that's what
he told me
it's like you guys go way back you know
it's like you shoot him attack in a
different life
he's up to you oh i'm gonna do the same
thing
hey so me and steve yeah or as you call
him steve wheezy yeah steve i'm gonna
say hey oh kev okay what's going on over
there
i'm actually just gonna send an email
[Music]
you